Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History, and we are ripping our way through the 32 countries that are participating in the World Cup in Qatar. And Dominic, today we are coming to Denmark. And Denmark, of course, has already, we've already had a football tournament inspired episode on Denmark, haven't we? Because last, summer before last, during the Euros, we, England ended up playing against Denmark in, what was it, the semifinals, I think. And so we did an episode on Anglo-Danish relations over the course of the centuries.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们深受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》，我们正在盘点参加卡塔尔世界杯的 32 个国家。多米尼克，今天我们来到了丹麦。说到丹麦，我们以前当然也做过一期受足球锦标赛启发关于丹麦的节目，对吧？因为去年夏天，前年夏天，在欧洲杯期间，英格兰最后在半决赛中对阵丹麦，我想是半决赛吧。所以我们做了一期关于几个世纪以来英英关系的节目。
But today we're looking at a distinct, and I have to say a very noble moment in Danish history. So what have you chosen to represent Denmark? Well, lots of people would anticipate that when we're doing a podcast on Denmark, we would do something to do with the Vikings. And I've gone to completely the opposite end of the spectrum. We are in the 20th century and we are doing what's almost a first for the rest of history, Tom, because we are doing what is, I think we can say, safely say is an almost entirely good news story because most historical stories end with everybody dying, don't they?
但今天我们要探讨的是丹麦历史上一个独特且必须说非常崇高的时刻。那么你选择了什么来代表丹麦呢？嗯，很多人可能会预料，当我们做一个关于丹麦的播客时，我们会做一些与维京人有关的事情。而我选择了完全相反的方向。我们身处 20 世纪，我们正在做一件对《历史的余烬》来说几乎是破天荒的事情，汤姆，因为我们正在讲述一个，我想我们可以满怀信心地说，几乎完全是好消息的故事，因为绝大多数历史故事都是以所有人死去告终的，对吧？
Yeah. And when they're packed with incidents, that basically means there's an awful lot of fighting or something of that ilk. But this is a story in which people actually, and some very surprising people, behave really rather well. So the story is the rescue of the Danish Jews. During the Second World War.
是的。当故事充满了冲突时，基本上意味着有大量的战斗或类似性质的事情。但这是一个人们实际上——而且是一些非常令人惊讶的人——表现得相当好的故事。所以这个故事就是营救丹麦犹太人。在第二次世界大战期间。
During the Second World War. And we'll start with Denmark right at the beginning of the Second World War. So the Second World War breaks out, as everybody should know, in September 1939. And Denmark is formally neutral. But from the end of that year, Hitler and the German leadership have plans basically to occupy Denmark because they want to occupy Norway. They want Norway for its access to minerals. They think it's very important for resources.
在第二次世界大战期间。我们将从二战刚开始时的丹麦讲起。二战爆发，正如所有人应该知道的，是在 1939 年 9 月。丹麦当时是正式中立的。但从那年年底开始，希特勒和德国领导层基本上就有了占领丹麦的计划，因为他们想占领挪威。他们想要挪威的矿产资源。他们认为挪威对资源至关重要。
It's uranium. Is that right? Exactly. Things coming in from Sweden and so on to the coast of Norway. But they don't think they can get Norway for strategic reasons without also taking Denmark because they can't allow Denmark to fall into British or French hands. So they draw up these plans to occupy Denmarkmark and they strike very suddenly and very effectively 4 15 9th of april 1940 the germans pile across the border they they just make holstein exactly exactly which of course they fought a war with
是铀。对吗？正是如此。从瑞典等地运往挪威海岸的东西等等。但出于战略原因，他们认为如果不顺便拿下丹麦，就无法拿下挪威，因为他们不能容许丹麦落入英国或法国手中。因此，他们制定了这些占领丹麦的计划，并在 1940 年 4 月 9 日凌晨 4 点 15 分发起了非常突然且非常有效的袭击。德国人蜂拥过境，他们越过了荷尔斯泰因， exatamente， exactamente，当然他们在 60 年代曾为此与丹麦人打过一场仗，我想是 60 年代吧。他们卸下了船。他们在哥本哈根港的运兵船上准备好了人员。他们涌上码头。有一些抵抗。16 名丹麦士兵阵亡。但在仅仅两个小时后，所以我说过入侵开始于 4 点 15 分，大约在 6 点 15 分，丹麦政府认为大势已去，下令投降。到了早上 8 点 34 分整，
the danes about um in the60s, I think it was. They're unloaded. They've got men ready in the troop ships in Copenhagen Harbor. They pile onto the quays. There's a little bit of resistance. 16 Danish soldiers are killed. But after just two hours, so I said the invasion began at 4.15. At about 6.15, the Danish government decides that the game is up and orders a surrender. And by 8.34, exactly in the morning,
丹麦人已经正式投降了。换句话说，如果你在 4 月 8 日的晚上上床睡觉，你完全有可能连觉都还没醒。打开新闻，心想“天哪，发生了什么事，哦，不，我们被纳粹占领了，我们被入侵了，而且我们已经投降了”。现在有时人们会说这表现太差了，但丹麦当然是非常平坦的，日德兰半岛非常平坦，他们与德国有陆地边界，他们绝无可能抵挡住德国人。他们只有一支微不足道的军队，他们面对的是希特勒战争机器的强大力量。从他们的角度来看，投降在某种程度上是合乎情理的，继续抵抗绝对是徒劳的。但这是一个带有一点转折的占领，因为德国人所做的是，他们表示丹麦基本上将成为一个德国保护国，但他们将允许丹麦在自己的内政方面保持独立。那么为什么会这样呢？好吧，显然丹麦和德国有着相当交织、融为一体的历史。由于 19 世纪中叶关于石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因的战争，这里存在很多积怨。但在德国人眼里，丹麦人是同胞雅利安人。具有北欧血统。是的，北欧血统。
the Danes have formally capitulated. So in other words, if you went to bed on the night of the 8th of April, you could plausibly not even have woken up. Turn the news on. i wonder if anything's happened oh my god but we're occupied by the nazis we've been evaded and we've surrendered already now sometimes people say this is very this is very poor performance by the danes but of course denmark is very flat jutland um is very flat they have a land border with germany there is no conceivable way that they can hold out against the Germans. They only have a tiny army. They're facing the might of Hitler's war machine. It kind of makes
他们认为他们可以把丹麦当作一种样板，当作一个示范保护国，来展示在希特勒的新秩序下欧洲人的生活会是什么样。他们还想从丹麦获取大量的食物、乳制品和所有这些东西。培根。培根。不，他们真的是想要所有这些东西，汤姆。他们认为如果丹麦人配合，他们就能把这件事做得最好。所以丹麦人对德国人采取的做法是，他们有这样一种政策，他们称之为合作，但不是勾结。换句话说，他们对被占领并不高兴。他们不会做超出绝对最低限度的事情。但同样地，他们也不会故意激怒德国人。比如暗杀当地的纳粹领导人之类的。是的。所以发生的事情是，德国人允许他们拥有自己的政府、议会、自己的警察和法院。事实上，他们的国王克里斯蒂安十世也得以留在国内。但这个国家将首先由德国大使管理，其次由一个名叫维纳·贝斯特的党卫军将军管理，我们将在播客后面重新提到他。对于丹麦以外的人来说，这其中最著名的一面是国王克里斯蒂安十世的遭遇。他快 70 岁了。
sense from their point of view to surrender, to fight on would be absolutely futile. But this is an occupation with a slight twist, because what they do is the Germans say that Denmark will basically be a German protectorate, but they will allow the Danes independence in their own kind of domestic affairs. So why is it that this happens? Well, obviously Denmark and Germany have kind of quite interlinked, intermingled histories. There's a lot of bad blood because of the war about Schleswig-Holstein in the mid-19th century. But to the Germans, the Danes are fellow Aryans. Of Nordic stock. Yeah, Nordic stock.
他绝对是，如果你让选角公司提供一个 20 世纪初那种高贵、正直的斯堪的纳维亚国王，克里斯蒂安十世就是你要找的人。他在制服里显得非常严肃和僵硬，但他有着极强的尊严感、爱国主义等等。他做了这件著名的日常事情，如果你看电影胶片、新闻短片，其实非常感人。在德国占领期间，他每天都骑着他的马“朱比利”，
They think that they can run Denmark as a kind of, as a sort of model, as a model protectorate to show what life will be like for Europeans under Hitler's new order. And they also want to get a lot of food and dairy stuff and all these kinds of things from Denmark. Bacon. Bacon. No, they genuinely want all that stuff, Tom. And they think that they can do it best if the Danes cooperate. So what the Danes are doing with the Germans is they have this sort of policy, which they call kind of cooperation, but not collaboration. In other words, they're not happy about being occupied. And then they're not going to do more
在没有卫兵陪同的情况下穿过哥本哈根的街道。人们站在那里观看，他们佩戴着带有国王徽章或丹麦国旗的小徽章，来象征他们对他的支持，他们鼓掌、鞠躬或者行礼。他骑马穿过街道，基本上作为一个活生生的象征，表明丹麦的主权依然存在，总有一天他们会重获自由。这与那些遭到更残酷入侵且王室逃往伦敦的其他欧洲国家形成了鲜明的对比。完全正确。所以克里斯蒂安十世仍然是民族自豪感和抵抗的焦点，尽管他仍然留守国内。
than the bare minimum. But equally, they're not going to sort of willfully provoke the Germans. So kind of assassinating local Nazi leaders and things. Yeah. And so what happens is the Germans allow them to have their own government and to have their parliament and to run their own police and to run their own courts. And indeed, they're the king, King Christian X, to remain in the country. But they will have the country run, first of all, by the German ambassador and secondly, by an SS general called Werner Best, who we will come back to later in the podcast. So people outside Denmark, the most famous aspect of this is what happens to the king, Christian X. He's almost 70.
是的，完全正确。所以他留在了那里。我猜他留在那儿作为丹麦的化身。许多人对二战中丹麦的另一了解是，国王和丹麦政客们明确表示，他们绝不接受针对犹太人口的任何镇压措施。因此，丹麦的犹太人口非常少。大约有 6,000 人，再加上几百名相关的家庭成员等等。所以你可以将它与邻国荷兰进行对比，那里有 140,000 名犹太人被德国人占领；或者波兰，那里有超过 300 万犹太人。
He is the absolute, if you am asked a casting agency to supply a kind of noble, upstanding Scandinavian king from the early part of the 20th century, Christian X is your man. He looks very austere and very stiff in his uniform, but he's got a tremendous sense of dignity and patriotism and stuff. And he does this famous thing, and they're actually very moving if you watch the clips, the newsreel clips. During the German occupation, every day he mounts his horse, Jubilee,
所以丹麦的犹太人口虽然极少，但他们融入得非常非常好。因此几乎没有什么差异感，反犹太主义也很少。尤其是国王明确表示，他绝不接受对犹太人的任何迫害。所以关于他流传最广的故事是，如果德国人强迫丹麦犹太人佩戴黄色六角星来识别自己、以此来做标记，他也会戴一个。这是真的吗？人们常常弄错的一点是，他们说他真的戴过。他绝对没有戴过。他绝对没戴，因为德国人从未推行过这项措施。但他说过那句话的故事是真的吗？但这个故事绝对是真的。
and he rides unaccompanied by guards through the streets of Copenhagen. And the people stand and watch, and they wear little buttons with the insignia of the king or the Danish flag to symbolize their support for him and they applaud or they bow or whatever. And he rides through the streets as basically a living symbol that Danish sovereignty still endures and that one day they will be free. And I kind of strike in contrast with other European countries that were more brutally invaded and whose royal families fled to London. Exactly. So Christian X is still serving as a focus for national pride and resistance, even though he's still in situ.
他与首相开会，并告诉首相——他后来在日记中写道——他说：“我告诉首相，我认为我们自己的犹太人是丹麦公民，德国人休想动他们。”这是令人钦佩的行为。所以国王对此绝对是坚定不移的。丹麦有着这种无比令人钦佩的，我的意思是，我爱丹麦。我毫不掩饰我对丹麦以及所有斯堪的纳维亚国家的爱。但在二战前的几年里，丹麦有着一种非常社会民主主义、反极权主义的政治文化。他们产生了一种意识，即我们都是丹麦人，我们绝不允许占领者将我们分裂。
Yeah, exactly. So he's remaining there. He's remaining there as the embodiment of Denmark, I suppose. The other thing that a lot of people may know about Denmark in the Second World War is that the king makes it very clear, and Danish politicians make it very clear, that they will not accept any repressive measures against their Jewish population. So the Jewish population in Denmark is very small. So there's about 6,000 people, and then several hundred people more who are sort of associated family members and so on. So you compare that with the Netherlands, nearby country occupied by the Germans, where there are 140,000 Jews, or indeed Poland, where there are more than 3 million.
现在，德国人显然觉得这非常烦人。事实上，希特勒觉得克里斯蒂安十世国王极其烦人。随着时间的推移，尽管丹麦的抵抗规模很小，但德国人对丹麦人的态度也越来越恼火。最著名的例子就是 1942 年 10 月发生的所谓“电报危机”。这是一个滑稽的故事。国王迎来了 72 岁生日，希特勒希望能巴结他，以便，你知道的，也许能让丹麦人听话。他给国王发了一封热情洋溢的电报，祝他生日快乐。
So the Danish Jewish population is tiny, but it's very, very well assimilated. So there's very little sense of kind of difference and very little anti-Semitism. And the king in particular makes it very clear that he will not accept any persecution of the Jews. So the most famous story that's told about him is that if the Germans make the Danish Jews wear a yellow star to identify themselves, to sort of mark them out, he will wear one too. Is that true? Well, what people often get wrong is they say he did wear one. He definitely didn't. He definitely didn't because the Germans never introduced the measure. But that story of him saying that is true, is it? But the story is absolutely true.
而国王回了一条信息，只有一行字：“Sprecher meinen besten Dank aus Christian Rex”，大致翻译过来就是：“多谢了，国王克里斯蒂安。”希特勒对这种被打发的方式感到非常愤怒。他实际上从哥本哈根召回了他的大使，并将丹麦驻德国大使驱逐出境，因为国王言简意赅的电报深深冒犯了他。沉默寡言。沉默寡言，正是如此。这种冷淡的回应。
He has a meeting with his prime minister and he tells his prime minister, he writes in his diary afterwards, he says, I told the prime minister that I consider our own Jews to be Danish citizens and the Germans cannot touch them. That is admirable behavior. So the king is absolutely adamant about this. And Denmark has this immensely admirable, I mean, I love Denmark. I'm completely unashamed in my love of Denmark and indeed all Scandinavian countries. But Denmark in the years before the Second World War has a very kind of social democratic, anti-totalitarian political culture. There's a sort of sense that they've developed that we're all Danes together, and we will not allow the occupiers to break us apart.
但我的意思是，这非常符合皇室、斯堪的纳维亚皇室的行为风格，不是吗？我的意思是，我认为他们通常会发送更热情的回复，汤姆。你不这么认为吗？如果我明天向丹麦王室发送一条祝贺信息，我希望自己能收到一条更热情的回复。
Now, the Germans obviously find that very annoying. And indeed, Hitler finds King Christian X enormously annoying. And over time, although the Danish resistance is quite small scale, over time, the Germans become crosser and crosser with the Danes. So the most famous example is something called the Telegram Crisis in October 1942. This is a hilarious story. The king turns 72 and Hitler, who's hoping to sort of butter him up in order to, you know, maybe get the Danes to play ball. He sends an effusive telegram to the king to wish him happy birthday.
不，如果是 20 世纪中叶的话，就不会。我希望收到一份非常严厉和正式的回复。如果我没有收到，坦白说我会感到失望的。是吗？是的。我不希望有任何形式的情感流露之类的事情。我倒希望他们对这个播客的回应能更热情一些。我期待听到丹麦王室对这个播客的看法。
And the king sends back a message, which is just one line, which is Sprecher meinen besten Dank aus Christian Rex, which basically translates as, thanks a lot, King Christian. Which Hitler is absolutely furious that he has been sort of fobbed off in this way. He actually recalls his ambassador from Copenhagen, and he kicks the Danish ambassador out of Germany because he's so offended by the king's perfunctory telegram. Taciturnity. Taciturnity, exactly. This sort of cold response.
还行吧。所以，是的。感谢你们的播客。感谢你们的播客。我们没听过，但我们很感激。电报危机为长达数月不断恶化的关系拉开了序幕。丹麦爆发了罢工，人们越来越拒绝与德国人合作。1943 年 8 月，德国人向丹麦人提出了最后通牒，
But I mean, that's very kind of royal, Scandinavian royal behaviour, isn't it? I mean, I think they would normally send a more effusive reply, Tom. Do you not think? If I sent a message of congratulations tomorrow to the Danish royal family, I would like to think I'd receive a more effusive message.
他们基本上说，把事情解决好。你知道，制止罢工，禁止公众集会。我们要求你们审查报纸。当然，德国人此时正处于焦虑不安的状态。那是 1943 年，战争进展不顺。他们在斯大林格勒遭遇了惨败等等。所以他们整体上处于紧张状态。而丹麦人则表示：绝对没门。所以在 1943 年 8 月底，德国人解散了丹麦政府并宣布戒严。他们说，别再装模作样了，现在由我们说了算。显然在这个时候，德国人认为现在是对大约 6,000 名丹麦犹太人及其家属采取行动的时候了。这是动手的时刻。现在，一个真正具有英雄主义色彩的人物登场了，这就是德国人，德国驻哥本哈根大使馆的一名外交官，名叫格奥尔格·费迪南德·杜克维茨。名字真棒，杜克维茨有着悠久的……他和丹麦人有着深厚的历史渊源，他在 20 世纪 20 年代就曾在哥本哈根居住过多年，自 1932 年以来他实际上一直是一名纳粹党员，但他属于——我知道这听起来对某些听众来说很奇怪——纳粹党内的左翼。所以比起民族主义，他更偏向社会主义。
No, but not if they were mid-20th century. I would hope for a very stiff and formal reply. I'd be frankly disappointed if I didn't get one. Would you? Yeah. I wouldn't want any kind of emoting or anything like that. I would like to think that their response to this podcast will be more effusive. I look forward to hearing what the Danish royal family
正是如此。他曾遇到过一个名叫格雷戈尔·施特拉塞尔的人，后者是纳粹运动早期的重要人物之一，
make of this podcast. It was all right. So, yes. Thank you for your podcast. Thank you for your podcast. We haven't listened to it, but we appreciate it. The telegram crisis sets the scene for months of worsening relations. And there are strikes in Denmark, and people are increasingly refusing to cooperate with the Germans. The Germans in August 1943 present the Danes with an ultimatum,
但非常强调社会主义而不是国家社会主义。而杜克维茨，这个外交官式的人物，他曾想，也许纳粹会成为斯堪的纳维亚社会民主主义的德国民族主义对等物，你知道的。他在德国大使馆工作。但随着时间的推移，他开始对正在发生的事情感到矛盾。他与现在负责丹麦的党卫军将军紧密合作。就是这个叫维纳·贝斯特的家伙。
and they basically say, sort it out. You know, cut the strikes, ban on public assembly. We want you to censor your newspapers. Of course, the Germans are jittery at this stage. It's 1943, the war's not going well. They've had the disaster at Stalingrad and so on. So they're just generally on edge. And the Danes say, absolutely no way. So at the end of August 1943, the Germans dissolve the Danish government and they declare martial law. And they say, enough of this sort of pretense, we're running the show now. And obviously at this point, the Germans think now is the time to move against the 6,000 or so Danish Jews and their dependents. This is the moment to strike. And now a genuinely heroic figure enters the story and this is a german a german attache at the embassy
在 1943 年 9 月初，维纳·贝斯特对他说：“我们正计划围捕所有的丹麦犹太人并将他们驱逐出境。我们现在就要处理他们。”为什么维纳·贝斯特要告诉杜克维茨这个？嗯，我们中场休息后再谈维纳·贝斯特，因为那是个有趣的故事。杜克维茨认为这是个糟糕的主意。他不喜欢这样。我想他不喜欢，不仅是因为他本身觉得不妥，还因为他认为这会彻底激怒丹麦人，导致根本无法管理这个国家。这会引发大规模的抵抗。杜克维茨去了柏林，他说我不
in copenhagen who is called georg ferdinand duck fits great name and hair duck fits has he's got a long history of with the danes he lived in copenhagen years before in the 1920s he'd actually been a nazi since 1932 but he was on the sort of, I know this will sound weird to some listeners, he was on the sort of left wing of the Nazi party. So more socialist than national. Exactly. He had met a guy called Gregor Strasser, who is one of the sort of early figures in the Nazi movement,
认为我们应该这样做，但没有人听他的。接着，有趣的是，他去了斯德哥尔摩开会，商讨德国商船运输事宜。在这次会议期间，他对瑞典人说：“如果发生围捕丹麦犹太人的事件，你们会接收丹麦犹太难民吗？”瑞典人说：“是的，我们可能会。”因为瑞典当然是中立的。而且瑞典和丹麦坐船只需要大约一个小时。所以丹麦犹太人可以逃到那里。我的意思是，汤姆，现在有桥了，如果你看过那部电视剧《桥》的话。当时还没有，但显然它足够窄，可以建一座桥。你去过那座桥吗？是的，我去过。去马尔默。
but very much on the sort of, had stressed the socialist rather than national socialist. And Duckwitz, this sort of diplomatic figure, he had thought, well, maybe the Nazis will be the sort of German nationalist equivalent of Scandinavian social democracy, you know. And he worked at the German embassy. But over time, he'd become conflicted about what was happening. And he works closely with the SS general who is now in charge of Denmark. He's this guy called Werner Best.
我们过了桥，我们过了桥——我必须说去马尔默——我们过了桥，当我们过桥的时候，我们在车里放了《桥》的主题曲。我太喜欢了，多米尼克，我对你放符合目的地音乐的做法表示大加赞赏，绝对如此，我绝对也这么做，尽管别人可能听不到。我从其他司机看我们的眼神中察觉到了一种疲惫感，当时我们开着车，伴随着《桥》的主题曲潜行。总之，我们不能被关于桥的话题分心。不，我们不能。
And at the beginning of September 1943, Werner Best says to him, we are planning to round up all the Danish Jews and deport them. We're going to deal with them now. Why does Werner Best tell Doug West this? Well, we'll come back to Werner Best after the break, because that's an interesting story. Doug Fitz thinks this is a terrible idea. He doesn't like it. I think he doesn't like it because he doesn't like it, but he also doesn't like it because he thinks it will really inflame the Danes and make it impossible to administer the country. It will provoke massive resistance. Doug Fitz goes to Berlin and he says, I don't
好。杜克维茨回到了哥本哈根，他联系了一位杰出的丹麦社会民主党政治家汉斯·赫托夫。他对他说：“听着，我们正计划围捕所有的犹太人。这是你们的机会。你们只有一个非常短暂的窗口期来采取行动。”赫托夫照做了。他与丹麦首席拉比会面，那个人叫马库斯·梅尔基奥尔。他对他说：“你必须告诉所有人，告诉他们所有人。因为人数相当少，你们还能做点什么。”
think we should do this and nobody listens. Then Then interestingly, he goes to Stockholm to have a meeting about German merchant shipping. And during this meeting, he says to the Swedes, if there's a roundup of the Danish Jews, would you receive Danish Jewish refugees? And the Swedes say, yeah, we might. Because Sweden, of course, is neutral. And Sweden and Denmark are only about an hour's boat ride apart. So the Danish Jews could get there. I mean, there is the bridge now, Tom, from the bridge, if you've watched the TV series. There wasn't then, but obviously it's narrow enough for there to be a bridge. Have you been over that bridge? Yeah, I have. To Malmö.
所以第二天就是犹太新年罗什哈纳节的前一天。马库斯·梅尔基奥尔走进犹太会堂，向哥本哈根的会众发表讲话。他说：“今天将没有礼拜。危机时刻已经到来。所有人回家，收拾好家当，打包行李，去躲藏起来。”因为当然，很多人已经考虑过在这种情况下该怎么做了。告诉你知道的每一个人，把消息传出去，我们必须这么做。与此同时，尽管议会已被解散，丹麦政府也不复存在，
We went over the bridge, and we went over i have to malmo we went over the bridge and we went over the bridge and as we went over the bridge we put on in the car the theme tune from the bridge i love that i dominate i so approve of the fact that you put on music appropriate to where you're going absolutely i absolutely do as well even though people couldn't hear it i detected in the in the sight of of other drivers a sense of weariness when they looked at us in our car, sneaking along to the theme from the bridge. Anyway, we mustn't get distracted by talk of the bridge. No, we mustn't.
这个国家显然仍由公务员在运转。是的。所以消息在丹麦公务员中传开了。他们互相叮嘱：“听着，联系你的朋友，告诉你认识的所有犹太人。甚至叫朋友们去翻电话簿，尽量给所有听起来像犹太名字的人打电话，告诉他们去躲藏。这是你们的时刻。”于是，一切都就绪了，犹太家庭开始悄悄从哥本哈根的街头消失。他们住进了朋友的家，或者去度假屋，或者被藏在地下室和阁楼里等等。与此同时，中场休息前，还发生了另一件事：最早逃跑、受到警告的人之一是物理学家尼尔斯·波尔。哦，对，绝对是20世纪原子研究乃至后来的曼哈顿计划中的泰斗级人物，据我所知，他好像是沃纳·冯·布劳恩的同事？那个德国火箭专家。是吗？
So, right. Doug Fitz, he gets back to Copenhagen, and he contacts a leading Danish social democratic politician called Hans Hedtoft. And he says to him, listen, we are planning to round up all the Jews. This is your chance. You have a very small window to do something about it. And Hedtoft does. He has a meeting with the chief rabbi of Denmark, who's a guy called Marcus Melchior. And he says, you've got to tell everybody, tell them all. Because of course, the numbers are quite small. You could do something.
这个我还真不知道，汤姆。国家剧院曾上演过一出戏，我看过。是迈克尔·弗雷写的《哥本哈根》吗？正是如此。所以我知道戏剧，但我对科学一无所知。所以这是……好吧，那是部戏剧。但我来告诉你尼尔斯·波尔做了什么。
So the next day is the day before the Jewish New Year, Rosh Hashanah. And Marcus Melchior goes into the synagogue and he addresses his congregation in Copenhagen. And he says, there will be no service today. This is the moment that the crisis has come. Everybody go home, sort out your affairs, pack your bags, go into hiding. Because of course, a lot of people have already had thought about what they would do in this situation. Tell everybody you know, spread the word, we must do it. Meanwhile, although the parliament has been kicked out and the Danish government is gone,
他是犹太人。他逃到了瑞典，到了瑞典——这是一个非凡的事实，汤姆——他决定，他认为他必须确保瑞典人会接收任何难民，于是他试图拜访瑞典国王古斯塔夫五世。顺便说一句，这个故事里的国王们表现都很好。这个故事涉及三个国家，汤姆，其中两个是君主国，一个是共和国。结果在这场故事中表现极佳的是君主国，而老实说，在这些年里让人失望的是共和国。
the country is still being run by civil servants, obviously. Yeah. So the word has spread among Danish civil servants. And they say to one another, listen, contact your friends, tell everybody you know who's Jewish. They even tell some of their friends to go through the telephone books and to try and ring everybody with Jewish sounding names, telling them, go into hiding. This is your moment. And so everything is sort of put into place and Jewish families start to sort of disappear quietly from the streets of Copenhagen. So they go into their friends' houses or they go to summer
你是在把德国称为共和国吗？是的。好吧，他们确实是个共和国，不是吗？是的，我想是的。绝对能证明（如果需要的话），君主制是最自然、最仁慈的政府形式。
houses or they're hidden in cellars and attics and so on and so forth. And meanwhile, just before the break, one other thing happens one of the people who has been warned who escapes very early on is the physicist neil's boar oh right yeah absolutely yeah titanic figures in the atomic research of the 20th century and later on in the manhattan project and who, I think, a colleague of Bernard von Braun, wasn't he? The German rocket guy. Was he?
好吧，我认为这是一个论辩性的结论，也许我们该休息一下了？我能讲讲发生在我身上的事吗？哦，当然可以。是的，是的。是的，是的。所以他想跟古斯塔夫五世国王谈谈，但古斯塔夫五世国王可不是随便什么人都见的，汤姆。
That I did not know, Tom. There was a play at the National Theatre, which I saw. Is it Copenhagen by Michael Frey? Yes, exactly so. So I know about plays, but I know nothing of science. So this is... Well, yeah, that was a play. But I'll tell you what Niels Bohr does.
好吧，他可是个国王。你需要有人为你从中斡旋，才能预约到国王，通过电话预约。你会向谁求助呢？你需要一个瑞典人。你需要一个 20 世纪的大牌瑞典人。呃，阿巴？不，他们当时还活着吗？不，汤姆，你会去找……你会找葛丽泰·嘉宝。是的，当然，你会找葛丽泰·嘉宝。葛丽泰·嘉宝本来就和尼尔斯·波尔是朋友——我不知道为什么，她显然比我对科学更感兴趣——她
He's Jewish. He escapes to sweden gets to sweden and this is an extraordinary fact tom he decides he he thinks he must make sure that the swedes will receive any refugees so he tries to get an audience with king gustav the fifth of sweden this is a story in which kings by the way coming out very well yeah there are three countries involved in this story tom two of them monarchies, and one of them is a republic. And it's the monarchies that emerge very well from this story, and the republic that frankly lets itself down during these years.
在国王面前为之说情。她为波尔争取到了一次会面机会。她给国王打电话说：“瞧瞧这个叫波尔的家伙。”国王说：“太好了，我们很乐意接纳丹麦犹太人等等。”于是 10 月 2 日，瑞典电台广播了一条消息，称所有丹麦犹太人都受到瑞典的欢迎。因此，一个伟大的好消息的舞台已经搭好，汤姆，我想我们应该在休息后接着讲这个。精彩的开局，多米尼克。谢谢你。正如多米尼克所说，我们休息后见。
Are you calling Germany the republic? Yeah. Well, they are a republic, aren't they? Yeah, I suppose. Yeah. Absolutely. Prove positive, if any were needed, that monarchy is the most natural and benevolent form of government.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐之巅》。这是你们每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及一波八秀八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
Well, I think that's a polemical payoff that perhaps we should take a break, should we? Can I just tell you what happens to me? Oh, yes, of course. Yes, yes. Yes, yes. So he wants to talk to King Gustav V, but King Gustav V doesn't just talk to anybody, Tom.
如果你想享受无广告收听、加更节目以及提前购买现场门票的特权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好，欢迎回到我们以丹麦为主题的“历史的余烬”节目。多米尼克，正如你所说，这是一个好消息的故事。所以丹麦犹太人面临着被纳粹占领者围捕的威胁。但多亏了那个……那个德国人叫什么名字来着？德雷克福德？德雷克福德，那是管威尔士的家伙。
Well, he's a king. You need somebody to intercede with you, to get an appointment with the king, a telephone appointment. Who would you turn to in that? You need a Swede. You need a big-name Swede from the 20th century uh abba no they're not alive no at this point tom you'd ask you'd ask greta garbo yeah of course you'd ask greta garbo and greta garbo who is already friends with niels bohr i don't know how she's clearly more interested in science than i am uh she
杜克维茨。杜克维茨。我就知道它和某种水鸟有关。真高兴看到你注意力这么集中，汤姆。好吧，我们应该提一下，到目前为止我们已经做了四期节目了。是的，今天。
intercedes with the king she gets boar an audience she rings the king and says see this fellow boar the king says yes splendid we'll happily take um danish jews and so on the 2nd of october swedish radio broadcasts a message to say that all danish jews are welcome in sweden and so the stage is set for a tremendous good news story, which Tom, I think we should come to after the break. Yeah. Wonderful setup, Dominic. Thank you. We will see you back, as Dominic said, after the break.
所以我的大脑开始有点儿转不动了。是的，所以是他、尼尔斯·波尔、葛丽泰·嘉宝以及丹麦和瑞典的国王们。他们在这场故事中都表现得非常好。但现在，我们要让整个丹麦人民在这场故事中大放异彩了。是的。所以，没有现成的网络来帮助这些躲藏起来的犹太家庭。除了丹麦人民的善意，什么都没有，汤姆。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
所以一切都属于家庭行径，没有组织，没有群众运动，什么都没有，全都是靠一个家庭接一个家庭的力量。人们住在海滨住宅里，寻找愿意把他们藏在教堂、医院、酒店等各种地方的人。当我们把所有孩子和家属等等加在一起时，这涉及将近 8,000 人。帮助他们的人是丹麦社会的绝佳缩影。基本上所有人都在帮他们。这真是丹麦社会的一个不可思议的缩影。字面意思上的屠夫、面包师和烛台制造匠。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to our Danish- themed rest is history episode um and dominic as you said a good news story um so the danish jews are under threat of being rounded up by the nazi occupiers um but thanks to um what was his name, the German? Drakeford? Drakeford, he's the bloke who's running Wales.
他们在夜色的掩护下从一个村庄转移到另一个村庄，来到海岸，西兰岛的海岸。当他们到达那里时，渔民们作为精明的企业家，通常会索取费用。当他们认为这些人有钱时，他们会说：“你知道的，我们会收点报酬，谢谢。”但他们是通过渔船、划艇运送的，难以置信的是，有时甚至是用皮划艇。在大约一个小时的时间里完成这个。非常有维京精神。非常有维京风格，穿过厄勒海峡，即分隔丹麦和瑞典的海峡。而德国人对此毫无察觉，是吗？好吧，我们一会儿就讲到德国人。
Duck Fitz. Duck Fitz. I knew it had some aquatic bird. Some aquatic bird link. It's great to see that you're paying so much attention, Tom. Well, we should mention to this, we've done four episodes so far. Yeah, today.
德国人开始注意到……因为他们一定，我的意思是，他们一定在监视……是的。监视着航运通道。非常，啊，好吧，这是一个非常重要的点，汤姆。你提出这一点很有洞察力。我们稍后，在五分钟左右再回到这个话题，但在此之前。
So my brain is starting to slightly flag. Yeah, so him and Niels Bohr and Greta Garbo and the kings, respectively, of Denmark and Sweden. And they're all coming out of the story very well. But now we're about to have the whole of the Danish people come out of this. Yes. So there is no network to help these Jewish families that have gone into hiding there was
德国人绝对在紧盯不放，因为当德国人在哥本哈根发起围捕时，他们心想：人都去哪儿了？他们全都消失了。所以这带有一种奇妙的色彩，令我惊奇的是，这个故事竟然没有被拍成好莱坞的大制作电影，因为它实在是个太棒的故事了。其中的某些方面几乎可以说是匪夷所思的具有电影感，简直就像一部伊灵喜剧。让我们聚焦于三个元素。你可以想象德国人如何在他们身后追赶到海岸，试图找到他们。我有三个特定的故事想简短地深入讲讲。所有这些帮助犹太人的小团体通常都有非常有趣的名字。
nothing tom but the goodwill of the danish people so all it's sort of family but there's no organization there's no mass movement there's no there's nothing like that it's on a family by family basis people stay in seaside homes they find people who hide them in churches, in hospitals, in hotels, all of these kinds of things. And we're talking about when you include all their children and sort of family members and so on, it's nearly 8,000 people. And the people who help them are this incredible cross-section of Danish. So basically everybody helps them. It's this incredible cross-section of Danish society. It literally is the butcher, the baker, and the candlestick maker.
比如说其中一个，叫做“赫尔辛格缝纫俱乐部”。赫尔辛格缝纫俱乐部是位于丹麦海岸赫尔辛格（因《哈姆雷特》而闻名）的四个人组成的团体。他们是当地的装订工埃尔灵·凯尔（Erling Kjær）、警官特莫德·拉尔森（Thermod Larsson）、警务文员奥维·布伦（Ove Brun），以及当地的报纸编辑伯格·伦内（Börger Rønne）。他们基本上在所有朋友中四处奔走。他们说：我们需要汽油，我们需要渔船，我们需要这个，我们需要那个。
And they move from village to village, undercover darkness and so on, to the coast, to the coast of Zealand. And when they get there, the fishermen, being canny entrepreneurs, they often charge. So when they think people have got money, they will say, you know, we'll take some payment, thank you. But they are transported on fishing boats, they're transported on rowboats, sometimes even in kayaks, unbelievably. It takes about an hour on this. Very Viking spirit. Very Viking, across the Oresund, which is the channel that divides Denmark and Sweden. And the Germans are oblivious to this, are they? Well, we'll come to the Germans in just a second.
他们帮助人们从赫尔辛格横渡到瑞典。事实上，直到今天，你依然可以在华盛顿特区的犹太人大屠杀纪念馆里看到他们的一艘船。你知道吗，多米尼克，那个大屠杀纪念馆是我去的第一个大屠杀纪念馆。当你参观时，你会感到整个人震惊不已。我记得走进了放着那艘船的房间。那是整个博物馆提供的第一线同情和希望的曙光。我记得自己毫无掩饰地放声痛哭。而且我不是唯一一个。我完全明白你的意思，汤姆。因为读到这个故事时，有一本丹麦报纸编辑博·利德高（Bo Lidegaard）用英文出版的精彩纪实作品，名为《同胞》（Countryman）。
The Germans start to get... Because they must have, I mean, they must be keeping an eye on the... Yes. On the shipping channels. Very, well, ah, well, this is a very important point, Tom. That's very astute of you to raise it. And we should come back to this in a little while, in five minutes or so, but just before this.
书中的有些故事是如此感人，我想如果不掉下眼泪，几乎很难读完它们。因为在黑暗、恐怖和所有善良与仁慈的毁灭之中，看着那艘船，读着那段记录，我永远不会忘记。永远不会忘记。哦，太好了。我很高兴你同意我的看法，因为我认为正是这种微观性、平凡感和……使得它如此感人。所以我原本要讲的三个例子中的第二个，是一个叫做“海峡之友”的团体，“海峡”指的是丹麦和瑞典之间的海峡。他们在一个——这基本上是由一个叫斯内克斯坦（Snekersten）村庄的客栈老板们组织的。
The Germans absolutely are sort of on their on their case because when the germans launched the roundup in cobenhagen they're like where is everybody they've all vanished so there's a slight sort of it's amazing to me that this is not being made into a huge budget kind of hollywood movie because it is such a good story and some of the aspects of it are almost sort of mind-bogglingly cinematic, just the sort of almost like an Ealing comedy. So to focus in on three elements. So you can imagine the Germans are sort of pursuing them to the coast, trying to find them. And there are three particular stories that I want to just hone in on very briefly. So all these little groups that help the Jews often have very entertaining names.
他们在斯内克斯坦的客栈会面。他们在客栈里接待了许多犹太家庭，也将他们安置在附近的民宅里。渔民和当地的村民们，仅凭他们自己就将近千人运送过了海峡，送到了瑞典。事实上，这个故事中有一个令人伤感的插曲。当地村民们，仅凭他们自己就将近千人运送过了海峡，送到了瑞典。而这个故事中其实有一个令人心酸的元素，那就是那位客栈老板，一个名叫亨利·克里斯滕（Henry Kristensen）的人，他先是被盖世太保逮捕，然后他们释放了他，之后由于他的抵抗活动，一年后他们再次逮捕了他，他最终死在了战争结束前的集中营里。所以，这是一个提醒。
So one of them, for example, is something called the Elsinore Sewing Club. And the Elsinore Sewing Club is a group of four people in Elsinore, or Helsingor on the Danish coast, famous, of course, from Hamlet. They're the local bookbinder, who's called Erling Kjær, the police officer, Thermod Larsson, the police clerk, Ove Brun, and the local newspaper editor, Börger Rønne. And they basically go around among all their friends. They say, we need gasoline, we need fishing boats, we need this, we need that.
我的意思是，这不仅仅是一部伊灵喜剧。对，不是的。我想要深入探讨的最后一点是关于一个叫格勒勒斯勒夫（Gilleleje）的沿海村庄。我确信我把这个词发错音了。所以丹麦听众们，我非常抱歉。在那里，同样发生了一些黑暗的事情。大约有 80 名犹太人藏在教堂里，藏在教堂阁楼里。
And they help people to cross from Helsingor into Sweden. And it's actually one of their boats that you can see to this day in the Holocaust Museum in Washington, D.C. Do you know, Dominic, that Holocaust Museum was the first Holocaust Museum I went to. And you just end up, you just feel kind of stunned as you go around it. And I remember going into the room where the boat was. And it was the first kind of glimpse of compassion and hope, almost, that that entire museum had offered. And I remember breaking into tears shamelessly. And I was not the only person. I know exactly what you mean, Tom. Because reading this story, there's a nice account of it called Countryman by Bo Lidegaard, a Danish newspaper editor, published in English.
据说是和一个德国士兵谈恋爱的一个女孩或者其他人说漏了嘴，暴露了他们的位置。结果除了一个躲在墓地墓碑后面的男孩之外，所有人都被捕了。但还有成百上千的犹太人及其家属藏在格勒勒斯勒夫，而德国人没有找到他们。德国人——这是一个精彩的故事——他们看到了掘墓人。掘墓人对盖世太保说：“可怜的犹太人。”德国盖世太保说：“圣经上写着这就是他们的命运。”掘墓人回答说：“但圣经没说非得发生在格勒勒斯勒夫。”当地人那种“我们绝不让这种事在这里发生”的决心是如此感人。这里有一个引语，有一个名叫威廉·林德（Wilhelm Lind）的工程系学生，他下定决心要提供帮助。
And some of the stories in that are so moving, I think it's hard to read them, actually, without sort of tears springing to your eyes. Because amid the darkness and the horror and the immolation of all kindness and charity, looking at that boat and reading the account, I've never forgotten it. Never forgotten it. Oh, good. I'm glad you agree with me because i think there's something about the small scaleness of it and the sort of ordinariness and the that makes it so moving so another example of the three examples i was going to give is a group called the friends of the sound and the sound being the the straight between denmark and Sweden. And they meet in a – this is basically organized by some innkeepers in a village called Snekersten.
他描述了在 10 月 6 日，他们基本上得到了德国人已经离开的信号，时机到了，他们可以出来了，是时候横渡海峡了。他回忆说：曾经那么宁静的海滨度假胜地，如今在秋色中静静伫立，街道几乎空无一人，却突然充满了生机。刹那间，所有的门都敞开了，犹太人从几乎每一栋房子里涌了出来。
So they meet at the inn in Snekersten. They put up a lot of Jewish families in the inn, and they put them up in nearby homes. And the fishermen and the sort of the local people, the local villagers there, they alone transported almost 1,000 people across the strait to Sweden. And there's actually a sad element to this story. people the local villagers there they alone transported almost a thousand people um across the strait to sweden and there's actually a sad element to this story which is that the innkeeper who was a guy called henry kristen he was arrested by the gestapo then they released him and then
瞬间，整条主街上挤满了人，有女人和男人，从最小的幼儿到满头白发的古稀老人，有穷人也有富人，都在逃离野蛮人。他帮助了一个小女孩。正如你所说，极其具有电影感。他帮助了这个小女孩。一个非常斯皮尔伯格式的细节，
later on because of his resistance activities they arrested him again a year later and he ended up in a concentration camp where he died before the end of the war. So that's, that's, well, that's a reminder of, of the fact. Yeah.
一个小女孩和家人走散了。她穿着一件红色的外套。威廉看到了她。他把她放在自行车的车把上，骑车来到码头，她上了船，驶向远方。他说：“我咽了又咽，很难忍住眼泪，不知道是因为一切进展顺利而感到喜悦，还是因为目睹 1943 年北欧发生这种事而感到痛苦，或者两者兼而有之。”总之，汤姆，共有 7,743 人渡过厄勒海峡到达瑞典，只有大约 580 名丹麦犹太人未能逃脱。我说只有，但当然，这其中的每一个人……
I mean, it's not just an alien comedy. Yeah, no, it's not. Yeah. And the final thing I want to hone in on is that is a particular village called Gila layer,
我的意思是，这不仅仅是一部外星人喜剧。对，没错，确实不是。对。我想重点讲的最后一件事是，有一个叫吉勒莱耶的特殊村庄，
which is on the coast. I'm sure I pronounced that wrong. So Danish listeners, I'm, I'm very sorry. So there, there is a, there is a bit of of, again, a bit of darkness. There are about 80 Jews hidden in the church, in the church loft.
它位于海岸线上。我确信我把这个词发音读错了。所以丹麦的听众们，我，我非常抱歉。所以那里，那里有，又有一点，再次充满了一点阴暗色彩。大约有80名犹太人藏在教堂里，藏在教堂阁楼里。
And supposedly the girlfriend, a girl who is going out with a German soldier or whatever, lets slip that they're there. And they are all captured except for a boy who hides behind a gravestone in the cemetery. But many hundreds more Jews and their families are hidden in Galileo and the Germans don't find them. And the Germans associate, it's a wonderful story that they see the grave digger. But the grave digger says to the gestapo the poor jews and the german gestapo guy says it's written in the bible that this shall be their fate and the grave digger says but it's not written that it has to happen in gilalea and that kind of determination of the local people that it won't you know we're going to make sure it doesn't
据说是女朋友，一个与德国士兵或什么人交往的女孩，无意中说漏嘴了他们在那里的消息。结果他们全被抓了，只有一个藏在墓地墓碑后面的男孩除外。但还有成百上千的犹太人及其家属藏在吉勒莱耶，德国人并没有发现他们。德国人认为，这是一个美妙的故事，他们看到了掘墓人。但掘墓人对盖世太保说：“可怜的犹太人”，而德国盖世太保说：“圣经上写了这就是他们的命运”，掘墓人则说：“但圣经上没写这必须在吉勒莱耶发生”。当地人民的那种坚定决心，认为不能——你知道的，我们要确保它不会
happen here it's so moving there's's one quotation, there's an engineering student called Wilhelm Lind who is determined to, he's one of the people who's helping them. And he describes how on the 6th of October, they basically get the signal the Germans have gone, it's time, they can come out, it's time for them to cross. And he says, he recalls afterwards, he says, the once so peaceful seaside resort, now sitting there quietly in autumn, with almost empty streets, was suddenly full of life. In a moment, all the doors sprang open and Jews flowed out of almost every house.
在这里发生，这太令人感动了。有一段引言，有一个名叫威廉·林德的工程系学生，他下定决心要——他是帮助他们的人之一。他描述了在10月6日那天，他们基本上收到了信号，德国人已经走了，时机到了，他们可以出来了，是时候让他们渡海了。他事后回忆说，他说道：“那个曾经平静的海滨度假胜地，现在静静地坐在秋色中，街道几乎空无一人，却突然充满了生机。一时间，所有的门都敞开了，犹太人从几乎每一栋房子里涌了出来。”
In an instant, the whole main street was full of people, women and men from the youngest toddlers to grey-haired old men, poor and rich, all on the run from the barbarians. And he helps a little girl. As you say, I mean, incredibly cinematic. Yeah, he helps this little girl. I mean, this very Spielberg detail,
刹那间，整条主街上都是人，有男有女，从最小的幼儿到满头白发的长者，穷人富人，都在逃离野蛮人的魔爪。他去帮一个小女孩。正如你所说，我的意思是，极其具有电影感。对，他帮了这个小女孩。我是说，这个非常斯皮尔伯格式的细节，
a little girl gets separated from her family. She's wearing a red coat. Exactly. And Wilhelm sees her. He puts her on the handlebars of his bike and he cycles to the quay and she gets on the boat and off they go. And he says, I swallowed and swallowed and found it hard to hold back the tears, whether it was the joy that everything seemed to go so well or the bitterness of having to witness that kind of thing in a Nordic country in the year 1943, or maybe because of both. So in total, Tom, 7,743 people crossed the Orison to Sweden, and only about 580 Danish Jews failed to escape. So I say only, but of course, each one of these
一个小女孩与家人失散了。她穿着一件红色外套。没错。威廉看到了她。他把她放在自行车的车把上，然后骑车赶往码头，她上了船，驶向远方。他说：“我不断地咽口水，发现很难忍住泪水，无论是为一切似乎都进展顺利的喜悦，还是不得不目睹1943年在北欧国家发生这种事情的苦涩，或者也许两者皆有。总之，汤姆，有7743人渡过厄勒海峡前往瑞典，只有大约580名丹麦犹太人未能逃脱。所以我说只有，但当然，这其中的每一个人”
people, I mean, it must have been absolutely awful. Some of them stay hidden in Denmark to the end of the war, but most of them who remain, 464, they're captured and they're sent to Theresienstadt, the concentration camp in Czechoslovakia. But even then, actually, there is kind of, I mean, it sounds weird to say an upside to the story, but the Danish are outraged at this. The Danish say to the Germans, we'll never cooperate with you unless you allow us to send food parcels, medicine parcels, and so on to these people. And as you promise us, you will not deport them to extermination camps. And unbelievably, the Germans don't. How many survived the war then? So the vast majority of those survived. So in total, more than 99% of Denmark's Jewish population
大家，我的意思是，那肯定非常糟糕。他们中的一些人藏在丹麦直到战争结束，但大多数留下来的人，即464人，被捕并被送往捷克斯洛伐克的特雷津施塔特集中营。但即便在那时，实际上也有点……我的意思是，说这个故事有积极的一面听起来很奇怪，但丹麦人对此感到愤怒。丹麦人对德国人说，除非你们允许我们向这些人发送食品包裹、药品包裹等，否则我们绝不与你们合作。而且正如你们向我们保证的那样，你们不会将他们驱逐到灭绝营。难以置信的是，德国人真的没有。那么到底有多少人在战争中幸存下来了呢？绝大多数都幸存了。因此，总的来说，丹麦99%以上的犹太人口
survived the war, which is a truly extraordinary thing. What is it about Denmark? Is it that it's possible to save them, whereas in other countries it's not? Is the tradition of antisemitism less toxic? I mean, what's going on? So historians, political scientists have spent oceans of ink on this question. Why is it that, for example, in Denmark, 99% of the Jewish population survived, whereas in, let us say, the Netherlands, so many thousands of people are killed? What one answer would be is that there isn't a neutral country within ready access across the beach. I mean, yeah. So there are multiple explanations.
在战争中幸存了下来，这是一件真正非凡的事情。丹麦究竟是怎么回事？是不是因为拯救他们是有可能的，而在其他国家则不然？反犹太主义的传统毒性较小吗？我的意思是，这到底是怎么回事？所以历史学家、政治科学家在这个问题上耗费了大量的笔墨。为什么，例如，在丹麦，99%的犹太人口幸存了下来，而在比如说荷兰，成千上万的人被杀了呢？一个答案可能是，没有一个可以通过海滩轻易到达的中立国。我是说，是的。所以有多种解释。
One very popular one, which Beau Lidegard gives in his book countrymen he says denmark had created something almost unique before the war which is this incredibly patriotic democratic civic culture in which danish jews were seen as danes like anybody else there's no virtually no anti-Semitism. And people genuinely thought it was their – they had a solidaristic civic culture in which people thought it was their duty to come together as Danes. You know, the king symbolizes this, all of this stuff. And there's a kind of tremendous sense of democratic citizenship. Hannah Arendt, in her book Eichmann and Jerusalem, she said, you know, that it's the sort of power of the human spirit. She says, Denmark is the only case we know of in which the Nazis met with open native resistance.
一个非常受欢迎的解释是博·利德加德在他的书《同胞》中提到的，他说丹麦在战前创造了一种几乎独一无二的东西，那就是这种令人难以置信的爱国、民主的公民文化，在这种文化中，丹麦犹太人被视为像其他人一样的丹麦人，几乎没有反犹太主义。人们真诚地认为这是他们的——他们拥有一个具有团结精神的公民文化，人们认为作为丹麦人团结起来是他们的责任。你知道，国王象征着这一切，诸如此类的事情。这里有一种对民主公民身份的巨大自豪感。汉娜·阿伦特在她的书《艾希曼在耶路撒冷》中说，你知道，这是人类精神的力量。她说，丹麦是我们所知道的纳粹遇到公开的本土抵抗的唯一案例。
And the results seem to be that those exposed to it changed their minds. They had met resistance based on principle and their toughness melted like butter and that in a way is that what you might call the sort of school assembly you know you can stand up to horrible evil all you need to do is but of course as you rightly say there is a bit more to it so first of all um there is the fact that sweden is so close and you it can be done in a way that it can't be done from the Netherlands or from France or something. Secondly, is the fact that Sweden has already, so the Swedes come out of this very well because they have publicly signaled that they will accept Jewish refugees in a way they didn't necessarily need to do.
而结果似乎是，那些接触到这种抵抗的人改变了他们的想法。他们遇到了基于原则的抵抗，他们的顽固像黄油一样融化了，在某种程度上，这就是你可能称之为学校集会的那种东西，你知道的，你可以站起来对抗可怕的邪恶，你只需要这样做，但当然，正如你所说，这背后还有更多原因。首先，嗯，有一个事实是瑞典离得这么近，以至于这可以以一种从荷兰或法国等地无法做到 A 的方式完成。其次，事实是瑞典已经——所以瑞典人在这方面表现得非常好，因为他们公开表示他们会接受犹太难民，而他们原本不一定非要这样做。
But it reflects very well on them. And did they suffer for that from the Nazis? No, they didn't. No, they didn't. And then the third thing, of course, is the Jewish population is just so small. It can be done in Denmark in a way that would have been very hard to do in, let's say, France or indeed in Holland. Is it also a fact that, well, Denmark, until martial law gets introduced, is treated with, relatively speaking, by Nazi standards, kid gloves. perhaps uh the the german occupiers are kind of less attuned to the idea that they can just shoot people willingly yes you're absolutely right tom and i think this is the other element in the story which is the i said that there were going to be surprising people who come out well and this is the other and most ambiguous element which is that
但这很好地反映了他们的品格。他们为此受到纳粹的迫害了吗？不，他们没有。不，他们没有。然后第三件事，当然是犹太人口太少了。这可以在丹麦实现，而在诸如法国或荷兰这样的地方，这会是非常难做到的。这也是一个事实吗，嗯，丹麦，在戒严令出台之前，以纳粹的标准来看，相对而言是被温和对待的。也许嗯德国占领者没有那么习惯他们可以随心所欲地枪杀人的想法？是的，汤姆，你绝对是对的，我认为这是故事的另一个要素，我刚才说过，会有意想不到的好人出现，而这是另一个也是最模糊的要素，那就是
the factor that perhaps is not discussed so much is that it's also a question of the Germans. So I said that the guy running Denmark was an SS general called Werner Best. And Werner Best, the thing that really is important to him is to, when Germany, it's embattled, it's short, it's got tremendously strict rationing it is short of all kinds of supplies the war is going badly his absolute priority is to maintain the flow of agricultural produce from denmark and he needs danish cooperation to do that so denmark is called during the war it's called germany's pantry or people talk about it as the whipped cream front because basically you made that joke about bacon but but that's absolutely right.
这个或许没有被讨论太多的因素是，这也是一个关于德国人的问题。所以我说过，管理丹麦的那个家伙是一个名叫维尔纳·贝斯特的党卫军将军。而维尔纳·贝斯特，真正对她重要的是，当德国陷入困境、物资匮乏、实行极其严格的配给制、各种物资都短缺、战争进展不顺利时，他的绝对优先事项是保持来自丹麦的农产品供应，他需要丹麦的合作来做到这一点。因此，丹麦在战争期间被称为德国的食品室，人们称之为鲜奶油前线，因为基本上你开了关于培根的那个玩笑，但——但那是完全正确的。
Well, it wasn't a joke. Because I know that before the war, Denmark was London's larder. Yeah, absolutely. And Best is absolutely, he thinks, we cannot risk sabotage and strikes and all this kind of thing. So when he actually organizes,
好吧，这不是一个玩笑。因为我知道在战前，丹麦是伦敦的食品储藏室。是的，绝对是。贝斯特绝对认为，我们不能冒破坏、罢工和诸如此类事情的风险。所以当他实际上组织时，
I mean, he's in charge of the Germans. When he organizes the roundup of the Jews, he tells the soldiers, you have to knock on the door first. You can't smash down any doors. You can't smash down windows. So there's actually a story of one family that actually, Jewish family, that are just asleep and sleep through the so-called rounding up. And they're never rounded up because they just didn't answer the door. You also asked about boats, and I said I would get to that, about why the Germans don't monitor shipping.
我的意思是，他是德国人的负责人。当他组织搜捕犹太人时，他告诉士兵，你们必须先敲门。你们不能砸碎任何门。你们不能砸碎窗户。所以实际上有一个故事，一个犹太家庭，他们只是在睡觉，睡过了所谓的搜捕。他们从未被搜捕，因为他们只是没有开门。你还问到船只的事，我说过我会讲到这个，为什么德国人不监控航运。
Best orders all German patrol boats into harbour during this period, these crucial few days at the beginning of October 1943. He says it's very important to repaint all our patrols right right um yeah he also i mean this is a very famous story he has this he has a jewish tailor in copenhagen called rafael bodin and best goes to get a suit measured just before the round up and he says to his tailor as he's leaving oh oh, by the way, you might want to go into hiding pretty soon and tell your friends. So in a weird way, the SS general who's in charge of the whole thing, and this is quite an Ealing comedy-ish element.
贝斯特在此期间下令所有德国巡逻艇进入港口，在1943年10月初的这关键几天里。他说重新粉刷我们所有的巡逻艇非常重要，对，对，嗯，他还——我的意思是这是一个非常著名的故事，他在哥本哈根有一个犹太裁缝叫拉斐尔·博丁，贝斯特在搜捕前夕去量制一套西装，他在离开时对他的裁缝说：“哦，对了，你可能很快就要去躲起来了，告诉你的朋友。”所以奇怪的是，负责整个事件的党卫军将军，这是一个相当具有伊灵喜剧风格的元素。
You can imagine a 1950s British film director enjoying casting the noble German or whatever. Well, okay, so what happens to him at the end of the war? He's a witness at the Nuremberg trials. He's sentenced to death by a Danish court because of his, obviously his role as the sort of plenipotentiary, the man running Denmark, but his sentence is reduced to 12 years on appeal.
你可以想象一个1950年代的英国电影导演很乐意挑选高贵的德国人或者其他什么角色。好吧，那么他在战争结束时怎么了？他是纽伦堡审判的证人。他被丹麦法庭判处死刑，因为他显然扮演了全权代表的角色，也就是管理丹麦的人，但他的刑期在上诉时被减为12年。
There are various sort of talk of war crimes, but he's never really, you know, he never suffers tremendous punishment um he joins and i mean best is that most people would say best is a sort of opportunist he's not an idealist by any means um he did this because he basically wanted the bacon i mean that's the sort of the the bizarre irony of the whole thing but the man who is the regarded as the a lot of people as the real hero is that bloke georg duck fits because him not drakeford duck fits not drake duck fits because
有各种关于战争罪行的讨论，但他从来没有真正，你知道的，他从未遭受过巨大的惩罚，嗯，他加入并——我的意思是，贝斯特，大多数人会说贝斯特是一个机会主义者，他绝不是一个理想主义者，他这样做是因为他基本上想要培根，我的意思是，这就是整个事情的怪异讽刺之处，但是被许多人视为真正英雄的那个人是那个叫格奥尔格·杜克维茨的家伙，因为他不是德雷克福德，是杜克维茨，不是德雷克，是杜克维茨，因为
him giving the the nod to the danish but he knew exactly what he was doing he gave the nod to the danish politicians who then told the chief rabbi who then told all the um his jewish congregation doug witt's after the war he after the war, his life is actually, it's quite a sort of, it's a happy ending. He becomes the West German ambassador to Denmark and then later to India. He becomes Secretary of State in the Foreign Office under Willy Brandt.
他向丹麦人使了个眼色，但他确切地知道自己在做什么。他向丹麦政客使了个眼色，政客们随后告诉了首席拉比，拉比又告诉了所有的……他的犹太会众。杜克维茨战后，他的生活实际上，这是一个相当不错的结局。他成为西德驻丹麦大使，后来又驻印度。他在维利·勃兰特领导的外交部担任国务秘书。
And in 1971, he is named Righteous Among the Nations by the Israeli government.'s his name is in the yad vashem holocaust memorial in israel and today tom if you go to yad vashem there is a tree which commemorates king christian the 10th and the danish resistance movement and there is a fishing boat from the village of it'slaia. It's such a – I went to – I think I mentioned this in the bonus episode we did. I went to Roskilde, just outside Copenhagen, where all the Danish –
1971年，他被以色列政府命名为“国际义人”。他的名字被刻在以色列的亚德瓦谢姆大屠杀纪念馆里。今天，汤姆，如果你去亚德瓦谢姆，那里有一棵树纪念克里斯蒂安十世国王和丹麦抵抗运动，还有一艘来自伊斯拉亚村的渔船。这真是——我去过——我想我在我们制作的番外篇里提到过这个。我去了哥本哈根郊外的罗斯基勒，那里所有的丹麦——
The Viking ships. Yes, but it also has a cathedral where the – so it's the Westminster Abbey of Denmark where the kings and queens are buried. And I saw Christian's grave. And I didn't know the story in the detail that you've told me today, but I was very much aware of it as being, yeah, I mean, an incredibly moving and powerful story. And one that, as you say, so much of history is, I think, gives you a slanted sense of of human nature
维京船。是的，但它也有一座大教堂，那里有——所以它是丹麦的威斯敏斯特教堂，国王和王后都埋葬在那里。我看到了克里斯蒂安的墓。我并不知道你今天讲给我的那些细节，但我非常清楚地知道它是一个令人难以置信的感人和强大的故事。而且正如你所说，正如很多历史所呈现的那样，我认为它会给你一种对人性的偏见感，
because that is what tends to get into the history books but this is one that reminds you that people can do good and be brave absolutely and yeah it's a so it's a lovely story i think because the there are lots of occasions where there are heroes in history, but not many where you can genuinely say pretty much an entire country did the right thing, behaved well. So it's possible that Denmark will come out best then of our 32 episodes. Yes. So I think Denmark and Costa Rica, Tom, they're my tips. For World Cup glory.
因为这往往是历史书所倾向于记录的，但这是一个提醒你人们可以做好事并表现勇敢的故事。绝对的，是的，这是一个美好的故事，我认为因为历史上有许多出现英雄的场合，但没有多少场合你可以真诚地说几乎整个国家都做了正确的事，表现得很好。所以丹麦可能会在我们这32集里表现最好。是的。所以我想丹麦和科斯塔里卡，汤姆，这是我的建议。为了世界杯的荣耀。
If we have a public vote on World Cup glory. Yeah, if there's a World Cup of good behaviour, I think they... Well, maybe when we finish all these, we could... Yeah, we can look back over it. Do some post-tournament analysis. That final between King Christian X and Don Pepe Figueres. It's the clash they're all talking about. OK, well, Dominic, that was great.
如果我们对世界杯荣耀进行公开投票。是的，如果有良好行为世界杯的话，我想他们……好吧，也许当我们完成所有这些之后，我们可以……是的，我们可以回顾一下。做一些赛后分析。克里斯蒂安十世国王和唐·佩佩·菲格雷斯之间的决赛。这就是大家都在谈论的对决。好吧，多米尼克，那太棒了。
Dare I say a tour de force. A very powerful and moving episode. And I hope everyone listening enjoyed it as much as I did. Thank you very much for that. I can't remember what we're coming back with next. Normal cynical form will be resumed next time, sadly. Yes. So thanks very much for listening bye
我敢说这是一场杰作。一个非常强大和感人的剧集。我希望每个收听的人都和我一样喜欢它。非常感谢你。我不记得我们下次要带什么回来了。下次将悲哀地恢复平常的讽刺风格。是的。非常感谢收听，再见
bye bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
再见，感谢收听《历史的其余部分》，想要收听番外篇、提前收听无广告节目并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、番外篇并提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。